Cubby's off the table I am being
reasonable
but cubby is off the table unless you
would like to think about your Williams
you can't be serious
Willie McCovey for Ted Williams that's
an insult
I love that show plenty of people love
collecting baseball memorabilia but one
fan is truly in a league of his own
attorney Marshall Fogle started amassing
his collection three decades ago now
it's recognized as one of the best
anywhere and some of it is on display at
a Colorado Museum Barry Petersen has the
story the thing about baseball is not
how much it is changed in its almost two
centuries but how little it's a
throwback on what people really think
America is all about
where do you stand at the national
anthem and take me out to the ballgame
on the seventh inning and Marshall Fogle
would know in 1996 he spent a hundred
twenty-one thousand dollars for a Mickey
Mantle card and then started amassing
one of the largest personal collections
of baseball memorabilia in America all
for the love of the game I don't care if
you're the banker of the town the
sheriff you are you know certain ethnic
or race you all went to the game you all
set pretty much together and you all
rooted for the home teeth and it was it
brought people together some pieces are
now on exhibit at history Colorado
Center in Denver like the handprint Babe
Ruth made for a palm reader so when you
the fan walk in to the exhibit you can
shake hands with favors and Joe DiMaggio
a slugger may be better known for his
274 day tumultuously to Marilyn Monroe
here a receipt for roses sent to her
long after their divorce there's a story
that he would send roses to her grave
every day every day when he was alive
why do you think he did that
never stopped loving her when we visited
the exhibit with Marshall
he drew a crowd when you go to a game
today is it still as much fun as it was
in the old days I believe so I think
it's because of the culture that we live
in it's what you do before the game as
well you played catch with your father
your mother and and it's a it's a coming
together of a family that's very busy in
life as opposed to years ago Jason
Hanson was the curator who put the
exhibit together with his own memories
of going to games with his father was it
like a chance to bond a chance to learn
a chance to pass on something that he
loved to you it's a chance to share time
together which is an increasingly
valuable commodity in this world since
it's Father's Day we ask this father of
two daughters about teaching them so dad
how old are the girls five and seven are
you gonna start playing catch with them
are they gonna be in Little League
we already did you play catch of course
Marshall has baseball's signs of
changing times like when players
endorsed cigarettes or after Jackie
Robinson broke the color barrier in the
all-white major leagues
there were comics so young black
children could believe their dreams
would come true as well and then there's
Lou Gehrig who developed ALS Marshall
has one of the last original pictures of
Gehrig relegated to the dugout as
disease stole his skills but if you look
closely at his face you can see and
imagine what he must be thinking
something's wrong because he's sick and
maybe I won't be able to play anymore
and there was even a story behind his
last words to fans about the game he
loved Joe McCarthy the manager said Lou
you got to say something so whatever he
said that day came from his heart and
not from a script and that's why this is
the thing Marshall cherishes the most in
his last days an ailing Gehrig gave this
back to a
named Jerry here's the inscription to
Jerry may you take better advantage of
this than I did and it's signed Lew
Garrick what does that tell you about
Lou Gehrig it tells me that this is like
his whole career was humble no no no
matter how great even in 1936 when he
won the MVP award he always was a
gentleman always cared about people and
you just can't help but want to use him
as a role model even today it's still
the same game on a summer's day nine
guys against one lonely batter and as
the man who is collected so many
memories knows well it's still what it
has always been it's so simple when life
is so complex and when you add all that
together it comes out that baseball's
magic for CBS this morning Saturday
Barry Petersen Denver that is one
incredible collection I had some pretty
cool baseball cards but it seemed like I
always lost them to my brother who
convinced me to trade them away you
don't have any of them now no by the way
I don't know who produced that piece but
thank you for that cup shot you know
because a shadow